one of the questions which the me2
movement has always wanted answered
how did powerful men for so long manage
to get away with indecent or criminal
behavior tonight two people who worked
for the man whose alleged crimes started
me to Harvey Weinstein have told Sky
News their stories one said that naivety
wasn't an excuse and that the behavior
had seemed shrug off herbal and both
said Weinstein's brother Bob with whom
he ran his company was aware of his
behavior a lawyer leading a class action
against Harvey Weinstein says the number
of women he targeted could be near a
thousand a warning that our US
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peters
report contains sexual language
Bob and Harvey Weinstein worked together
for decades building an entertainment
empire that started with their first
company Miramax after Harvey was accused
by dozens of women of sexual harassment
and assault
Bob insisted he didn't know the extent
of his brother's alleged behavior now
two former employees speaking on camera
for the first time say that's hard to
believe Michael a post alina who was
head of creative affairs at Miramax
says that nearly 30 years ago a serious
allegation emerged and was widely
discussed amongst the staff after
1990-91 there's no way they could not
have known because a lawsuit was
delivered to the office it was
disseminated verbally about what the
contents of this lawsuit were which was
that he had attacked sexually attacked
or molested an intern and it all made
sense because this this young woman she
had worked there for a while she was
very very young very eager and one day
just poof she vanished
everybody started talking about it and
more started coming out so we knew
everybody knew everybody knew people
might listen to these stories and say
you had a responsibility I do something
I did I did and you didn't and I didn't
why not
that's a difficult question to answer I
I want to fall back on I was in my early
20s and it was naivete but that's not
really an excuse it's not that we didn't
have a concept of sexual harassment but
we just we didn't know what to do with
it oh this is terrible but this is what
I did
it seemed shrugs awful you know Kathy
[ __ ] Asst was Bob Weinstein's
assistant at the time
up until the lawsuit arrived she thought
Harvey's behavior was distasteful but
nothing more you would see something out
of the corner of your eye when you're
running down a hallway like Harvey
flirting with a new blond receptionist
out at the front and you're like okay so
he's just being a weasel you know
whatever but never did I ever think that
there was more than that going on he was
just being kind of lecherous you know
cheating on his wife but then she opened
the letter from the interns lawyers and
of course it enraged me so I was
completely not only disgusted and
furious and just just completely
disgusted after an argument with Bob she
left and I said you know what I quit and
your brother is pig Cathy's been angered
by Bob's claims that he didn't know the
extent of Harvey's alleged behavior and
says it's inconceivable to her that a
settlement happened without Bob's
involvement do you think that Bob knew
what his brother might have been doing
behind closed doors well he certainly
knew when I handed him the letter that
came from the law office Harvey got a
letter Bob got a letter Bob knew of
course he knew Bob Weinstein and others
are now being sued in a class-action
lawsuit that in part alleges they knew
about Harvey Weinstein's pattern of
predatory sexual conduct towards women
and failed to stop him the lawyer
leading the case says that failure had
devastating consequences how many women
do you think Harvey Weinstein may have
targeted we're talking about hundreds I
think it could be near a thousand I I
think that based on what we know and
what has already been made public at
least 150 women have come forward in
some way on top of that we have
employees who said that there were women
in his office three times a week where
he would they would have to go in and
clean up after him knowing that he had
just done something
so if you're talking about three times a
week at least for all the number of
years that he's been in power of Miramax
and the weinstein company that that's a
lot of women in a statement Bob
Weinstein said as I have previously
stated I had no knowledge that Harvey
was sexually assaulting or harassing
women prior to the media reports last
year detailing his alleged misconduct
these allegations relate to alleged
misconduct by Harvey there would have
occurred at least 28 years ago and I
have absolutely no recollection of the
incident in question Harvey Weinstein
who also faces criminal charges denies
all allegations of non-consensual sexual
conduct Hanna Thomas Peter Sky News in
New York